what's happening there reject nation we have
made it to the finale part one of stranger
things season four and this is also part one of
our reaction to stranger things for uh the finale
because this is a long long episode i'm ready
to chew it all up right now uh so yeah i have
to cut it up into two parts if you want to watch
part two if it's up now there's a card here's a
link of in the pin comment or something when it
when it's up in case this is the first one you're
watching but in the meantime i want to say thank
you to everyone who joined our patreon page became
a super sexy reject full-length watch launch we
single with the time code for stranger things and
a bunch of other shows with his exclusive reaction
highlights over at our patreon page and uh please
leave a like that would be very much appreciated
and subscribe and click the notification bell
to get notified when our next video is up and
thank you to the boys at prepper for helping
us edit down these highlights would not have
been able to do this without your help with
all the things we have to cover and also on top of
moving so yeah let's get to it guys it's a big one
oh
they made it
god they're like face huggers with wings
oh god
this is their monster effects runner
what do we call these demo bats demodactyls
oh wow stephen steve see
jesus christ oh my god twice
he's going to buy to bite the head
off one of those things at some point
there's not that many
that's demented music hope
you remember your way back
oh my god they're really gonna explore the
upside down i'm so excited hell on earth
this poor cop just don't kill killer
justice for faceless agent
guy who helped us number
two going back to the strong coke cans the
door is always open this place is not a prison
this is you could learn a lot from this john
i'm taking notes and what exactly
were you all doing at the lake
watch pork having beers going for a walk a
walk at 9pm to the lake take a little swim
how's that coming and nancy was she with you
at this night swim no yes oh we're not sure
nope no we have we haven't heard
absolutely we barely know the guy
who oh that's a bunch of bulls erica i mean you
realize they're lying the whole couch is on fire
shut up
that was the day he became a true sheriff
this eddie guys just had the worst week ever it's
racked up so much trauma in
such a small amount of time
jesus i'm fine i'm fine no no no no
no you're not you're losing blood
oh no oh what's happening
you ready yeah just do it
gooey well we don't have to go
all the way downtown for guns
i have guns in my bedroom lots of guns
a russian macarov and a revolver yeah
you almost shot me with that one you almost
deserved it you guys are so cute together
yeah so gun seemed like a pretty good idea to me
lots of guns even if we somehow
kill this beast we still must escape
we fail there i don't think they will be
so kind as to throw us back in the cell
they will shoot us on site
we die as monster slayers
it must be hardwired into us to reject our fathers
so we can grow move on become something
of our own i hope that's what she's doing
coming into her own you have no idea man well
maybe i should give that prayer thing a try
if we want to get out of here i'm going to
get back to ellen mikhail you and me we're
going to need a miracle hey man monsters and a
hellscape exist why not god you guys can beat it
hey
last night your sister 11 suffered a concussion
during her alone time in the rainbow room oh
those guys all deserve to die someone did
this who's going to tell me what happened
you've seen her papa she's clumsy stupid you're
very pleased with yourself you guys are not coy
i'm going to murder these children before
you right now let this be a lesson to you all
damn justice is getting served
the hell are you gonna do brenner
what happened it was an accident
catholic school all over again i've been through
worse henderson told me you were a badass
kid worships you dude like you have no idea
it's kind of annoying to be honest i don't
even know why i care what that little
shrimp thinks but uh he has that effect
outside of d d i am no hero we don't know about
that the wheeler right there she didn't waste a
second she just dove right in i would get her back
is that this has unambiguous sign of true love
are we back at the trailer park you don't
think they went through through watergate
without us without a plan without weapons they
wouldn't be that stupid please here's the deal
either you tell me what's happening or i
told dustin what i found under your bed
please no spill your guts photos of mike
serial killer is a dark wizard from the
upside down and we've been looking for
him but he's in the upside down which
we can't reach at least we thought we
couldn't until we found a gate at lovers
lake that was the reason why we were
so what if with each kill he's not simply killing
them he's making a powerful psychic connection
with his victims a connection powerful enough
to rip a hole in the fabric of time and space
he's opening more gates oh damn more
gates oh why would he be opening gates
to take over the world who do we know
that wants to take over the world
the mind players so if the demogorgon was just
his foot soldier feckness his five-star general
holy [__] holy [__] that was incomprehensible
you lost me at mother gate please be kind rewind
oh no oh no
or maybe it's our friends
oh that's right
those aren't guns i threw these away years ago
is it frozen in time those are the cards of
steve yeah hey these are from sophomore chemistry
and this this wallpaper this this
is old wallpaper time travel yeah
this diary should be full of entries it's not
the last entry is november 6 1983. the day
will went missing the day the gate open
we're in the past cool dustin
dustin dustin all right either this kid
can't hear us or he's being a total douchebag
you need a communication device lights
what are you getting at
that's beautiful
there you go dusty bun hey uh
remember when i said they wouldn't be
stupid enough to go through watergate
beautiful present you got here how about
this how about that huh you look so goopy
so nice to meet you uh i'm yuri of course but
allow me to introduce you to my favorite oh my god
we are we are so close
oh we are laughing and we are friends
you russians have good dry comedic timing
it's the official comedy of
the motherland would be 18
my dude let us hope your prayers have been heard
again come on he's being watched now but once
he is released he and the others are going to
attempt to kill you right here they don't
even realize it but he is moving them like
pieces on this board here this is a metaphor
you frighten him and he also knows he can't
control you i saw all this happening that's
why i wanted to help you but i only made
things worse helping me made papa hurt you
or this is all part of papa's plan why do
you still help because i believe in you
i really want to believe in you too dude
wow this is an important ass character then
yeah so this is the day she
like that led into season one
yeah hey
ah smart the light bright oh cool
oh my god light brights are gonna be so back
in style after this okay you guys seeing this
holy [__]
oh cool that's so cool hi hi that worked
my mind went too stupid uh you
can't get back through watergate
perfect yes yes yes okay we think we have a
theory that can help with that genius genius child
how many times do i have to be right on
the money before you guys just trust me
jesus christ this kid's got to get
his econ check it's his tone right
dustin's two surrogate dads completely
creepily frozen in time and [__] but
haven't you always had bikes the four
kids had bikes too led officer callahan
i guess it's just a minor misdemeanor
that's a poster right there too
oh that's so cool nice
this is kind of like the poster with all the
different roads leading to the inevitable
how are you feeling today okay
are you up for some more lessons
he's got like an evil abraham
lincoln thing about him
boy sounds like daniel day
lewis's room yeah thank you
the light is hurting my head she says she's
still dizzy lights are hurting her hurting whoo
oh no
oh this is the same night she got away i don't
think so not without that massacre this will lead
you out beyond the laugh fence to the woods can
you feel it it weakens me tracks me even if there
were another way out he will find me and if he
finds me he will find you you help me i help you
you still can't fit through that hole i mean
maybe she could do something about the hole
this is a [__] horrifying
man yeah this is so scary okay
oh just you wait my dude
come on hopper come on hopper light it on fire
i wonder how much bigger it's gotten yeah
it's uh last season finale be a sumo gorgon
cause the fight
oh boy oh buddy boy
i've been built up all season it's goddamn
then i'm afraid you're going to have to kill me
because your friend is
already dead come on come on
oh man
oh my god oh it's been a minute oh
oh jesus
get it
oh come on guys
this is
oh my god that flame's going out i
know ah there's some poetic irony
twice we have no idea what these
buttons do you can't just press away
like we got no choice man come on
it was a choice
when i get out of here i swear to god
jesus of course
oh nice
i throw javelin in my spare time
please don't tell me as i was injured
your angel your miracle angel your miracle angel
oh
oh i can't move it guys
that's sorry it's that's what i meant
hey guys that's the end of our stranger
things finale part one reaction part two
should be up in like two to three hours
or depending on the time you're watching
this it's already up and there's a card right
above you or there's an end screen right here
you